it's great to be joined today by Tom
Nichols who is a professor and also
author of the book the death of
expertise this is a really interesting
topic to me and I'm so glad to have you
on to talk about it the idea of
expertise particularly in the media
world and in the political world has
been an increasingly important topic
really no matter what political issues
one follows give us sort of a general
sense of what you identified as being an
issue within the world of expertise that
led you to write this book in the first
place well the what I initially reacted
to was not people doubting expertise I
mean that's normal if you're a
professional you kind of get used to
that I mean people seek second opinions
from doctors they go get a second
opinion from a lawyer they get multiple
bids from contractors what led me to
write the the initial blog post because
this wasn't even a book it was kind of a
rant was people deciding that they were
smarter than experts and specifically in
one evening people who decided they were
smarter than me about Russia I had a
young person tell me we were talking
about the Edward Snowden business and a
young person said to me tell them that I
don't think you understand Russia now
I'm a Russia expert a Russian speaking
Russian expert had been in the business
for you know 30 years and that finally
kind of you know popped my top when
someone said you know let me explain
Russia to you and this had actually been
germinating for a while I've been
talking up until that point with people
who were experts and things like
intelligence doctors you name it just in
random conversations where they said
yeah you know people keep lecturing me
about what I'm good at and that's what
kind of triggered the idea wasn't that
people doubt experts or have concerns
about expertise it was the experiences
of my experiences along with those of
other experts and professionals who were
really puzzled by people explaining I
suppose you know a lot of women have
said to me this is what man's flaming
feels like but
people explaining your own area of
expertise back to you as though you
don't really understand it yeah and I've
noticed that there a particulate we
don't have to get into them but there
are particular political issues where
this is really prevalent one is
certainly climate change and climate
science and there's a lot of others that
we could talk about it seems that there
is this complexity because you do on the
one hand have a logical fallacy called
the appeal to Authority right suggesting
that something either is right or
couldn't be right based on the perceived
or actual sort of authority of the
person making an assertion but that is
very separate from the reality that
training and education in subjects do
contribute to expertise so how can we
sort of square or or put together those
two sides well one of most important
things about the fallacy of the appeal
to authorities that most people don't
understand it they don't understand that
when someone says look you know you
should listen to me about Russia because
I'm an expert on Russia they say oh well
that's just an appeal to Authority
that's not an appeal to Authority that's
presenting your bona fides appeal to
Authority is saying because I'm you know
a professor you should listen to me
about you know health care or exercise
or something people never understand
this that that they have really become
allergic that when someone says look I'm
a doctor you know you should listen to
me about your heart they say oh that's
an appeal to Authority they think that
it means any authority is an appeal to
Authority and you know it's an irony
that in the death of expertise when
people argue about expertise they don't
even understand the fallacies they're
using and of course if you correct them
then you're being condescending and an
expert and all the things that people
hate I think though the way one way to
square in this problem is that experts
and I think this is one place I could
have improved the book if I may do some
self-criticism is that experts need to
be better about explaining why they're
right I admit that I kind of lose my
patience with people who say well why
should I listen to you because at some
point you do run out of patience with
that it's like yes it'd be like a
student walking into class every day
I know you're the professor and I know
you were hired by Boston College to
teach this course but tell me again why
I should listen to you on the other hand
I think you need to be persuasive and I
think you do need to put out your case
and you do need to be willing to go that
distance as long as people are willing
to listen to you in good faith which i
think is another problem in in the
modern this modern phenomenon of death
for expertise people just aren't willing
to listen how much has basically Google
I guess is what we would call it or the
availability of opinion about just about
any issue on the Internet impacted the
sort of perceived credibility of experts
well I find it fascinating that people
who don't trust New York Times don't
trust the Washington Post don't trust
the Wall Street Journal don't trust
college professors don't trust science
will trust any stray bit of detritus
that goes in front of their screen on
the internet I still argue and I would
still argue now and I argued in the book
that this whole phenomenon predates the
internet I really think this is an
outcome of the late 1960s and relevance
and higher education and therapeutic
models of education child rearing and a
lot of other problems that contributed
to an overall increase in narcissism in
American society but the Internet is an
easy crutch you know because it allows
us to just find basically it allows us
to confirm anything we already believe
and I find that it's I find it amazing
that people who say well I need evidence
and I don't just take the words of
experts will go and type in a search
term in Google and just accept whatever
pops up in further eyes because it's
pretty it's easy to read it's well
presented you know one of the great
curses of the internet is that anything
in 12-point font looks authoritative and
I think that you know that's that is a
real problem is it's not the source of
the depth of expertise but it's really
something that's put it on steroids how
much does this connect to these sort of
pseudo
intellectual movement that's been in the
United States now more and more strongly
over the last decades I've made the case
and reasonable people can disagree but
I've made the case that pseudo
intellectual ISM is in many ways more
dangerous than anti intellectualism once
you have people reading you know Bill
O'Reilly book about the death of Abraham
Lodi the life of Abraham Lincoln or the
death of day of care whatever and
believing that they are scholars of
history for example or reading books by
people like Mark Levin and Laura
Ingraham or whoever that their belief
that they have sort of explored a
variety of viewpoints from experts etc
that that can actually be more dangerous
than just straight out anti
intellectualism I'd be curious to hear
your thoughts and also if and how this
connects to expertise well I I don't I
guess I would part company with you on
the semantics I don't think of you know
Bill O'Reilly books as
pseudo-intellectual I think of them as
anti intellectual I really do so I guess
I should say they are perceived as maybe
intellectual by some of the audience of
for them I mean in a way you know why do
people like Bill O'Reilly books because
they it seems to arm you with knowledge
without actually making you do the work
and I I think you know pseudo
intellectual ism maybe you know this is
just a semantic difference but I don't
really encounter pseudo intellectual ism
as much as I used to say in the 70s or
the 80s people whose people for example
when I think of a pseudo intellectual I
say I think of someone who says oh yes
you know could I find Camus so tiresome
when in fact you know this person has
never read Camus you know or you know I
have some very deep thoughts on
reconstruction and the post slavery you
know period when you know this is not a
person who's ever thought about it
anti-intellectualism says I don't really
need an informed opinion about this my
gut
in fact my opinion is better about this
because I'm just a working job hmm you
know you know why Bill O'Reilly books
are better because he's not a professor
he's not one of you snotty over educated
footnoting kind of intellectuals he's
just an ordinary guy just like you
me and that's why his books are great
and I think that's actually more
dangerous because it's not just junk
it's tasty junk it's it's yummy junk you
know I mean books I I tried reading
killing Reagan because it's an area I
have a lot of knowledge and I Michael I
have some background as a cold war
historian and I you know I was alive
during Reagan I'm working in Washington
and it's crap but it's easy to read crap
so it's not even like that
I guess pseudo-intellectuals lie about
difficult books they can't read anti
intellectuals really do read bad books
and and celebrate it and glory in it and
on speaking of the of textbooks I mean
because you mentioned Bill O'Reilly not
a professor in the book you have a
chapter called higher ed the customer is
always right can you tell us a little
bit about how that factors into this
yeah I think you know college when it
was a natural sorting function for know
let me back up and say college was also
you know class-based experience
wealthier kids went you know not ever
kid that just you know Jonathan any went
to Harvard and he was a C student I mean
this was not always the the province of
bright kids it was off in the province
of rich kids but College throughout the
50s and 60s and into the 70s needs to
serve to sort of natural sorting
function that you know if you went to
college because you were really
interested in going to college now
college is a mass experience we really
do we really have internalized this
belief that everybody should go to
college and the problem is that devalues
a college education because the
competition for those tuition dollars
excuse me the competition for those
tuition dollars really does make
colleges the lower tier colleges not not
not Harvard and Yale I mean Harvard and
Yale our roads can have their
valedictorian but it makes middle and
lower tier colleges have to compete for
students and treat them like clients
rather than students and that means that
you're not going to fail the customer
you're not going to make them
uncomfortable you're not going to be too
challenging you start adverts as I talk
in the book talk about the
you start advertising things like dorms
that our little apartment so you don't
have to pick roommates that you don't
like rock climbing and kayaking and
basically a whole bunch of things that
really have nothing to do with education
when you treat students like clients
you're not treating them like students
College is supposed to be uncomfortable
it's supposed to be where you get
challenged and you know there are times
you should walk out of class really
unhappy but we live in a therapeutic
culture where you know especially in an
educational culture where the students
are always supposed to be happy and
we're always asking them if they're
happy and I think that's really
contributing to the inability to keep
learning even after college and
everything it doesn't mean much now when
a student says well I have a university
education that that may or may not mean
anything anymore but it convinces that
student I'm smart I I don't really need
to learn more than I know and they're
not really equipped to keep learning and
I think that's that's a real tragedy in
Western education we've been speaking
about the book the death of expertise
with the book's author Tom Nichols
thanks so much for talking to us about
this very interesting thanks for having
me